it's daddy season because my dad is here
bride and Kellie the points guy the girl
in the green scarf welcome thanks for
having me I always reppin two as a girl
in green scarf and I know you don't know
who that is I know it's all my to-do
list to watch but she's helping people
she was the original influencer she was
the original points guy okay oh my god
you have to watch I need to watch the
movie it's like you're coming brings my
color - yes it's a good emerald scarf
you just you have to watch the movie the
Bryan Kelly's here he's gonna host with
me friend of the toast friend of the
family and also just like knowledgeable
entrepreneur and he took me on a private
jet so like he has to be here you know
we got a lot of questions were you
offended by my Talbots comment okay it's
just so funny that you say that so I put
up an Instagram on my Instagram Minister
I mean looking glamorous in my corporate
chic outfit getting on the private jet
and Brian Kelly put a comment saying
that I was on my way to a Talbots tambul
sample sale and what's so funny i dinner
last night literally next to her Talbots
on the Upper East Side and I was just
laughing the whole time and I just I
wanted to ask you about that because I
was wondering like what you've been by
that like no because when I was growing
up in Doylestown Pennsylvania there was
a Talbot and my mom like we're very like
she's she's not fancy and she would
always be like Talbots is for Arby's I
was like mom and she's like rich [ __ ]
oh my god so from my perspective it's
like but like very business forward like
I don't know that what is the tub what
did it mean to you to me and then boring
Upper East Side which is the same thing
is it I just thought it would like
Talbot I feel like it's an aggressive
businesswoman is it well you know what I
literally never set foot inside Talbots
so I didn't know what to think of
because my perception of Talbot liked it
though there's always been this one on
the Upper East Side and like it's I've
never seen anyone in there but it's
always always saving business you've got
it I have to go now I got to get some
Talbot chic I bet it's very much I
guarantee within six weeks you will be a
Talbots ambassador I was gonna say
hashtag sponsored by toggles well we're
gonna run through the Fast Five talk
about all things housewives all things
travel with TBG but then at the end of
the show we're gonna be taking questions
I've been sourcing them from Instagram
YouTube and all over the interwebs and
if you have any questions for TVG about
credit cards about points about the
Boeing 737 Boeing I know but like it's
just meant to be pronounced boy right
yeah I like that
yes they should rebrand I mean they're
also like having some problems so maybe
they really should rebrand right I read
on TBG comm that the stock is going down
we're gonna talk about that later in the
show but before we do that we are gonna
sit here with TBG and deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast so there's a lot
going on in the house websphere you are
very invested in house I'm very I'm so
excited Potomac scumming back are you
gonna watch the season so you've been
trying to get me into Potomac and you
also try to get me into Rome with love
you said it was the best show on Bravo
yeah like one one weekend in the
Hamptons we're gonna lock us up you will
live you will trust the process but I
find like that I was renewed though I do
sound it's I just caught up on Atlanta
and you were really like an Atlanta kind
of soaring you're also invested in a
ladder you're friendly with Phaedra yes
and you out here trying to get justice
for Phaedra Phaedra is the best Phaedra
is actually a nice ass lady yeah she's
so fun and we love her friendship with
Star Jones yes star was a lot of fun we
had where we were at Empire and our
table was just so great it was me Oh
Jackie Ben ha there we have it bad Star
Jones Star Jones Phaedra Lindsey
Silberman Simon Simon Huck it was
seriously like the most ragtag I love it
I got to keep people on their toes you
really do like you have now surrounded
yourself with just such a great crew of
yellow-bellied losers oh I remember when
I first moved to New York like 12 years
ago it was was when housewives were just
started and my friend had invited me to
this Bravo up front party and it was it
was I remember being like oh my god my
DVR just exploded I remember going up
the housewives shaking literally I would
be so starstruck with Alex McCord you
always referencing Alex McCord you will
literally have a conversation in your
sole focus will be like how glad
references back to Alex McCord she's
lost in Australia now she is a
psychiatrist
yeah and I'm actually personal Facebook
friends with her my facebook like that
was when Facebook like celebrities I
don't know it's like let me just friend
it yeah I think she came downstairs in
your Herman Munster shoes there Louie
Vuitton knows even atomic are you gonna
watch no but I know you will love Karen
huger I'm a huge Karen huger I just
wanna show you once held a press
conference cuz her friends were talking
[ __ ] on her she held a full-blown press
conference and didn't forget for her
friends to set the record straight about
her husband's tax escapes but
no I I just turn in questions the shower
and I was just like unimpressed yeah
well so I've been I now I'm caught up on
Atlanta and I've got to get your hot
takes on the Nene breakdown ripping the
producers sure well I'm almost sad you
know when they showed it in the clips
it's like Nene on unleash yes hey I
think it was a very loose t-shirt that
was ready to be ready was it well like
she said you know you open up as a
reality star your lies and if you have
to set certain boundaries I couldn't if
your closets a mess don't go in
someone's closet I'm also a closet is a
personal thing and even going upstairs
in someone's house like when I grew up
my parents were like you don't go
upstairs in people's house unless you're
like yeah and in general you don't do
that all the ladies were coming to
Nina's room she was like get out and
Nene was clearly like has been breaking
down slowly that was wild
so yeah you know Nene I'm like team Nene
on meet you and I love the new
housewives like I think they're all in
Atlanta like in New Yorker Beverly Hills
IDs strong stances against people but
I'm like loving although I wasn't
playing so I get plain emotional I was
watching I was watching the wedding you
say like I had a tear yeah she's
beautiful I'm not a huge IVA fan I'm I
do not like Nirvana Jalan I don't wanna
see about a housewife so don't eat
tonight a friend of a friend oh but
Tanya she yeah Kenya you hate her I hate
her I kind of like her she's a bossy
successful oh my god she's giving me the
camille Grammer thirst levels and I just
can't yeah and I really like Shamari
Shamari oh my god she has a drink yeah
totally but when she gets drunk she like
turns like I wanted to meet everyone and
I was actually thinking on the plane yes
I was like I don't
well Kim Richards aside I don't have we
really ever had a full-blown alcoholic
housewife like that on camera yeah we
have one right now don't you say it in
New York no it's how her you're thinking
it's all the way in because she's at
least out about during the doing is like
I'm she's sober no and I know that she's
not sober
oh yeah and like it's bad and also I
mean like this is uh this is Jesus these
are unlike these are like baseless
allegations but also Kellie Dodd oh yeah
you know it's on that they're like
alcohol it's what they're spiraling yes
you know but I mean us in Houston who's
who were we all said the drive-thru at
Whataburger like literally
like that's why people 30 36 year old
man of a fast food chain let I said you
should have a reality show I'm like no
you're fake cry that moment of that was
horrified we drove so far out of the way
to go to Whataburger and they're suppose
to be open 24 hours we were banging on
the door and they were like sorry we're
closed the drive-thru is open I like
thank God for the driver tipped our
driver like a hundred dollars well
because it was the back of his car was
just covered in ranch I like you because
I don't even like ranch
I love gran and like really doesn't like
Ram we were all so I do want anything we
were like begging him to take food he's
like no I don't want anything we're like
please take time you ordered so much we
have an extra chicken finger seven
drinks seven rings seven drinks
that was us major returned beverages at
Whataburger because we don't
accidentally ordered so many if you
watch my live stream you probably saw
the whole thing
mmm but so far we weren't that I mean we
just hungry
yeah and tired yeah I've been traveling
when you think about season one Real
Housewives of New York Alex McCord each
aimed for having nude photos remember
Ramona got up off the couch at the
Russian Tea Room during the reunion was
like I don't want to be a part of this
to where we are now at the Ramona and
Bethenny in the pool completely naked
like everyone just naked all the time
Bethenny and her movie you know it's
like how far we've come as a society
yeah it is it is it's amazing but let's
just talk about Barbara what are your
thoughts I'd like to I know Barbara
knows the first time we went to countess
and friends a year ago the first show
ever Barbara was one who gave us
chickens yes so the countess and Friends
was the hottest show in town
it really was it was impossible to get a
ticket so Barbara I know from the
Hamptons and like I'd like Barbara can
you explain the choices just a little
confused as to her job
is she a contractor just architect yes
Barbara is a contractor so do you want
to be legit contractor evergreen
construction so she does in the TPG
office building she so companies will
say I want a new headquarters and she'll
come in so she'll design and build oh I
don't know if she does design she builds
but then she also does project project
manager she actually TPG we're making a
new crazy headquarters yes oh yeah
toaster I should have a TPG toaster
party yes oh my god that'd be so let if
you want your new headquarters to be
destroyed in five minutes we have a to
BG like Ranger where are the guards
everyone runs out to Barney's the bar
back to Barbara I think she's a good
yeah you know so he's likable the way
that I'm seeing it's like they started
filming with the intention of making her
a housewife yes he knew first that she
was gonna be housewife but like I think
they started filming with every
intention of making her house a but they
were like disappointed in her
performance because she's not in the
intro she doesn't hold an apple yeah but
actually like like she says I don't need
to hold an apple I hold a hammer oh yes
I like her because she's on the side of
justice that I wish to seek which is the
LuAnn Bethenny Burnside I'm loving it I
like the serviceable aspect of her
Instagram she'll show how to like
spackle a wall although she just did a
hole it's very easy like spackle but it
like made no sense you know it's fun I
would totally have her do my house like
in three seconds know her works good
from what I hear yeah no I've only heard
good things from you okay so let's jump
right into the past five speaking of
housewives from page six apparently Lisa
Vanderpump and Lady Gaga had a girls
night out Lisa Vanderpump is far from
the shallow now Wow nice touch page six
the restaurant tour and Lady Gaga bounce
between Vanderpump Vanderpump's Los
Angeles hot spots pump and Tom Tom on
Sunday night an insider told paid chicks
once a time time they sat in the garden
and Gaga loved it it was a night of
girls being girls just like a girly
girls after Lisa just landed from Vegas
working all weekend and last week a new
venue banned from cocktail garden is set
to open at Caesars Las Vegas on April
1st do we have to go gotta cuz Celine
Dion's last show in Vegas is June oh my
god by the way we really have to go
gotta go we're told that banner from 58
and Gaga 32 did some deejaying at the
restaurants and took turns playing music
oh my god so anyway this was like a paid
in doors so it's this is disappointing
because it's obvious that Lisa Lady Gaga
has been like a housewives Stan shed
countess in her music video like she's
obsessed with housewives and she's
really invested in it I would say
obsessed with housewives
she loves Atlanta yeah but so if I'm
someone who's invested in housewives
specifically Beverly Hills I know that
Lisa Vanderpump is a manipulative shrew
so why would I be I've actually seen
Vanderpump what are you kidding are you
all caught up yes did you read the blogs
no read the blogs I'm a blogger I don't
read blog may you have to read the blogs
especially especially teddies because
they add a lot of color
I'm not Teddy I feel like that was the
smoking gun those printed taxes wait
just wait that's what they want you to
think but
but Teddy explains in her blogs o'madden
literally had to like teaches Taylor
Stryker this yesterday too it's like why
does nobody read the blogs Teddy owns
her part she said yes
I hated to read and me and Lisa had this
plan we should mention that the Bahamas
yeah but it's coming it's coming
yeah but she's a liar she lost credit
I'd I could I totally agree but when I
like I like how like the producer showed
the past seasons of her pretending yes
but wait just wait because what she says
is that they had this plan and they go
to Vanderpump dogs and Teddy does her
part of the plan she says is that Lucy
juicy Apple GU see whatever the dog's
name is and and then Lisa Vanderpump is
like stop I don't want to talk about it
and Teddy's very confused because they
had this highly orchestrated show so let
me l VP's evil because she wanted to
take down to rebut Teddy's not evil
because she wanted to take down no teddy
it was complicit but to read as well but
Lisa Vanderpump is manipulative to
another level like Teddy was just
playing the part Teddy hates to read not
sold no Jackie on jury duty no no you're
wrong you're wrong you are wrong Brian
or the toaster is going to come there's
no one else is this an unpopular
position people are pretty torn because
the way that it's being set up now it's
like Lisa Vanderpump is right so like
how did we get to six months or now her
like basically not gonna show up to the
reunion and fighting with Kyle and Ken
in her house you know because she just
lost her brother she doesn't need this
and for sure Eileen Davidson lost her
mom Eileen Davidson lost her mom like a
big day before they started filming and
nobody cared but now with Lisa
Vanderpump everyone's like oh it's so
sad but like listen your brother's
really sad like losing your parents
really sad but losing a brother it's all
sad night I actually got it wrong we're
LBP is the richest house place in all
history no yep
more than Bethany yep my brother in the
Hamptons last summer we did this trivia
game and my brother like God it just you
know I thought it was Bethany and Noel
be peace worth like 50 some million no
I'm sorry there's no way that LBP is
worth more than Lea black from Miami
she's not a housewife no she
you said passing over lea blacks
husband's a lawyer yeah but he was the
JFK lawyer no no they're they're totally
OPP how did you find that out I actually
did Google and the Google corroborates
my brother who's like a straight
housewife in his
they're gonna give me like housewives no
no it'll come up LVP Google yeah I yeah
here people don't come oh my god you're
right Lisa Vanderpump number one number
two Kyle Richards yeah oh this is a lie
number three Cowell RADS well there's no
this is wrong Wow
you're saying forward to me Kemsley five
kandi Burruss that I believe Oh six
Tinsley Mortimer she did another house
seven Bethany no way bet this is wrong
wrong wrong
I'm sorry countess no Dorinda no no it's
when you live in New York you really
know what's the source like sweater
people people that come I mean when you
live in New York you really can tell
based on where people live and like
sorry no people don't wealth whispers oh
not Housewives okay I want to check
another one slice ranking Real
Housewives Biden's number one number one
up totally wrong Teresa okay it's like
how shady all the house I was
financially dark is like they're all
like it's like they're all living in
mansions that are empty empty no
furniture alone who's the latest one oh
do you think Eva's a fraud I don't like
how it took that turn if I can we let
end the season on a high note but I
guess you have to end on some sort of
negative what is Eva's career she was
America's Next Top Model
I mean I'm not shocked I don't know what
she's poor there's lot of poor house
noises yeah and so what if you're not
I'm walkin yeah no Leeanne Locken owns
it yeah okay next up is another I did a
lot of housewife I do you think the
nfinity dress line selling I mean I
heard that like Berg dress is just like
died together but they can't get their
hands supply and it's a supply JD's Red
John John actually sorry our friend John
Janet
bought the dress and he does drag and he
wore the dress at Janet unofficial two
ends in Janet and he's so funny he
bought the N lock-ins prized possession
of what's are called infinity infinity
dress and honestly you look like a
snacks just [ __ ] in it
the DVD Awards he came out the
after-party looks so good never looks
bad no yeah but like he was looking like
snatch to the gods I did a lot of
housewives specific stories today um and
this one's really bizarre it's from paid
chicks and it says Taylor Armstrong says
daughter Kennedy doesn't miss late
husband Russell Armstrong does anyone
she okay former Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills star Taylor Armstrong says
her daughter doesn't miss her late
father
Armstrong revealed on Laura wass arse
divorce sucks podcast via the blast that
she brings up her late husband Russell
to their twelve-year-old daughter can be
often on the advice of her psyche a
psychiatrist quote so that she doesn't
think people just disappear okay so I
was saying do you miss daddy and she
said no and Oh
Armstrong 47 added that she tried to
bring up positive times that they shared
as a family but Kennedy still didn't
want to hear it quote she waited for a
minute and then she said why would you
miss a boy who screamed at you all the
time oh [ __ ] I mean I think I'm really
like Taylor Armstrong he's in a really
good place like from the place that she
was in like when her husband is like
what is the reason for her to do this
podcast yeah it's like she's not famous
anymore like there's talk about my
daughter's emotional stress on a podcast
yeah and it's like if you need a
psychiatrist for your daughter you
should be yes master can we skip to the
next one yeah like she was indicted for
crazy Ponzi scheme yeah abusive to her
but she's in a really good place now
she's a really good marriage I live in
Chicago or Aspen or something like that
like she's really come such a long way
it seems like weird to be doing a
podcast and maybe like airing just
daughters dirty laundry yeah my reason I
mean I do miss her do you think she'd
ever come back to Beverly no I think
she's like Brandi coming back as a
friend she's coming back in what like
two scenes gone to dinner with Denise
Richards what do you think of Denise
well I'm like bored by her so far I feel
like she only got I'm worried about her
is it husband now yes I ordered like a
quadruple tequila yeah although once
again where she we're shading people
after drinking but like we do that too
yeah so but it's like for Denise she got
the job because she's faint he's so hot
she got the job because she's famous but
she's so uninteresting hmm like her
house is uninteresting her family's like
there's nothing interesting and it's
funny her tagline is oh my realize much
more sure yeah yeah
she at least she's like bringing what we
what we needed her to bring which was I
didn't even know that Harry Hamlin was
married to Nicollette Sheridan who was
Ellie Britt on the Real Housewives I
mean on Desperate Housewives which is
just the connection it's just over and
she left Harry Hamlin and Harry Hamlin
when to Lisa Rinna and Lisa Rinna says
like the best thing that ever happened
to her wasn't it charitably because
iniquity earned and pretended like that
didn't happen yes your name is tweeting
and so now it's like okay Nicholas
Sheridan has to be a housewife
sure she's not returning on her she's on
dynasty she's not returning oh so she
really could use a Giants do the show oh
my god it's my show I was telling you
about it you know listen to me amnesia
is Kent contagious and apparently I gave
it to TCG well tell her I'm Chuck is in
a better place I do miss her like if you
can't be my friend then please don't be
my enemy Tilly Savannah prob see Lisa
Vanderpump has been manipulating since
season two Beverly Hills revisionist
history no no you have horse blinders on
you were one of those LBP stands on
Twitter who just refuses to listen to
logic no well this is the facts oh
please then read Teddy's blogs okay will
you be Teddy's logs can you send me the
link yes okay oh my god just do that
over here okay mmm
next story it was like taking the world
by storm a stray and I was really
shocked by it and this is from enews Amy
Schumer says her husband Chris Fisher is
on the autism spectrum
Amy Schumer has shared that her husband
Chris Fisher has quote autism spectrum
disorder in her upcoming Netflix special
Amy Schumer growing the 37 year old star
opens up about her personal life
including her marriage to Fisher the
couple who will welcome their first
child together this year recently
celebrated their first wedding
anniversary quote I knew from the
beginning that my husband's brain was a
little different than mine Schumer says
in the Netflix special I have to start
this over because I really want to get
this right because I love him very much
my husband was diagnosed with what used
to be called Asperger's he has autism
spectrum disorder he's on the spectrum
Schumer continues and there were some
signs early on
once he was diagnosed it was John Donne
me how funny it was because all the
characteristics that make it clear that
he's on the spectrum are all the reasons
that I fell madly in love with him
Schumer tells a Chicago audience in her
hour-long special that's the truth
he says whatever's on its mind he keeps
it real and he doesn't care what sort of
care about social norms or what you
expect him to do or say Schumer and chef
Fischer married in a surprise ceremony
in Malibu February 2018 just days after
going public with their
relationship this is so interesting
don't talk about it it's like awareness
and acceptance yeah I think it's so cool
I think it's very cool yeah
she's like so like on the ball always
like I've like progressivism you know I
wasn't joking no right so when I read
this story I didn't realize that she had
said it in your special don't you feel
like it's a weird place to announce it
yeah yeah so maybe is it a joke no she
wouldn't be joking no that'd be really
[ __ ] up but but she cancelled her tour
so how was she even doing a special I
don't know she's act like such an
interesting career
I saw her several times like years ago
and then she opened up for Madonna and
like oh yeah Uriel wasn't changing at
all oh did you see the same jokes over
and over like Oh everybody's like ok it
was like about the same things like
about Michelle Obama
like really crudely like having sex
having first lady walk like a duck back
to bed like it was like look a boat as
we say in my people that's terrible yeah
so it was like while the problem is I'm
holy as I know I know that's this you
know she's shocked yeah I mean Jackie
and I don't see the movie the I'm so
pretty early so these are amazing I just
don't like her stand-up and Jackie
starts Jedi bed and said the same thing
she said it was a saint material and it
was like really just like not funny
and Jackie said Bridget Everett opened
up oh whatever it was so funny got it I
saw Bridget Everett Skyy John Janet
Caleb and all my they loved Bridget
Everett we loved her it's wild she does
cabaret she does cabaret she sings she
dances she pulls her jugs
well the countess is like coming for her
for her spot I know and Bridget was in
the countess's first go oh yes I love a
little synergy yeah well so with this
with Amy Schumer it's like I love her
movies I think trainwreck was the best
funniest movie and I think I feel pretty
was good but it had an amazing message
and I loved it I felt like I was the
ideal audience for like the end was like
30 minutes it was stupid
yeah but the overall message it was like
very shallow Hal vibes you ever see
shark
oh my god we've got to get you a movie
like we do trust me of the week and you
need to start subscribing I should do it
well I just don't
I think her stand-ups like I think she
did an interesting thing with her career
cuz like five years ago I was like Amy
Schumer was the biggest thing in the
world it's like what Tiffany Haddish was
like a year yeah
what's up with her so she's doing
Groupon now she's doing this red she's
in that group on money yeah
she's isn't just like she's banging out
movie after movie she's like what cat
remember when Katherine Heigl was in the
same movie yeah for 100 times like
rom-coms with Gerard Butler that's what
she's doing now at Tiffany Haddish she's
in the same [ __ ] comedy with Kevin
Hart just like girls trip with my mom
the best mate my mom is the coolest
woman in the world but I was like was
there a penis in there was a lot of yeah
well rough night no girls night came out
the same week as rough night rough night
and girls trip yeah and they were
literally the same movies like five
girls like leaving their husbands at
home and like one of them is having a
mental breakdown so I get confused
between Odyssey which one is which it
made going into what have you been in
New Orleans no they look really fun for
it is really fun do you Marty you
haven't been how do you know I've been
to Mardi Gras oh I think haven't been in
New Orleans oh oh no I've definitely
been it was a lettuce [ __ ] yeah that's a
we let some New Orleans toasters in
Houston oh they were wild while I mean
oh yes we went to the bar with them yeah
beer buying shots when they came to the
bar with us yeah linguistic I have I
have toast star I was like yeah I start
looking around the bar scene and where
were we
Houston wasn't very lit on him it's kind
of was though cuz what's a toasters
arrived it was lit yeah at first it was
like there was a single go-go dancer jr.
Houston he was working hard he was
working hard by the end of the night
there was I mean we turned that it was
amazing there was a deaf drag queen
hosting at work ACOG no no she uh she
was blind oh yes and oh my god I totally
forgot about it was amazing Marlo we
made murderer when listing the torquing
party's gonna he's gonna kill me for
saying it but I videoed the whole thing
but I'll never post issues I'm Haley but
she won he won and yes well one of the
drag queens came out and was doing a
whole Celine Dion repertoire and we were
like I'm the number one sleep
Thole is hell we were like screaming and
I everyone was was tipping the dragon
and I went up and she wasn't taking the
money and someone came over and like
she's blind so you have to just you have
to touch her ankle I thought was so
interesting it was just like it was an
amazing show I mean her Monday night yes
I totally forgot about ago we've got to
go to Whataburger
what about like South by Southwest
you're like no we got to go to work
harder we did have to go to South by
Southwest we didn't make it we make it
we have to make a group apology for not
making it to south
they want to go to Austin you bet I felt
like no one blamed us for not gonna mean
apparently people in Austin that they
couldn't drive to work it was so it was
so foggy yeah but yeah if we would have
known earlier we should have just driven
it was like um yeah but by the time the
panel would've been over okay uh not
were you ready to tell her I'm trying
moving on this is like kind of a
dramatic story also from enews new
details have emerged after mama June's
arrest for drug possession I'm shocked
by this
I mean I am shocked by this but let's
not forget they got their award-winning
show canceled because her mom was
hanging at all
mama drugs let's see Mamadou designed
herself in some hot water an official
with the Macomb County District
Attorney's Office confirmed to e news
that June Shannon I didn't realize that
was her name June Shannon was arrested
for possession of a controlled substance
and drug paraphernalia last week people
reports at her boyfriend Gino dough AK
was also arrested TMZ reported on
Wednesday that the police were tipped
off about the alleged crimes when
someone called in a report of seeing two
people engage in a heated confrontation
at a nearby gas station I went to a
credit card they were using what credit
card is good for gas the city Thank You
premier do you know and mama June have
been together for three years they've
been she was even tweeting about her
boat just two days before her arrest
the reality star was sharing with her
Twitter followers some of the show's
most outrageous moments and mentioned
him on a few messages very Britney
Spears yeah I accept like a lot less
glamorous I mean I miss their show
everyday like when she was on toddlers
and tiaras and I took the world by storm
and they got their own reality show and
it was really good for like the first
couple seasons and then like it
unfortunately got to be awed by the fact
that her mother was bringing a child
predator home to her children but there
were so many great things about it I
mean mama June's oldest daughter was
pregnant and gave birth to a baby with
two thumbs remember it had a little
thumb and then like a branched off them
doughnut and pumpkin they were just
stars but really Alana was honey boo boo
child where's Alana today she's dancing
with the stars' jr. oh is she she's like
15 minutes yeah I mean it's actually
it's not good it's just all bad I mean I
actually thought the show was gonna be
really good for June in the audience
like loving it they don't know like you
know how like the pageant moms are
always like like mimicking the moves I
mean they also they gotta show how
majoun is she skinny now so she does
mama June
hot or not and the first season they
like gave her gastric bypass surgery and
she's so skinny now and I guess also
she's on drugs so like that makes her
skinny as well um so they're just out
here making premium content for the
trailer-trash of America yeah and I'm
appreciative it's a it's a line of
content that needs to be produced that's
true like someone's got to do it yeah I
mean I just wasn't really mad at mommy
Juun for like ruining a perfectly good
thing because like right when they got
canceled like they were about to move
out of their trailer like into this huge
mansion like it was like they were
moving the American Dream and she ruined
it with her child predator oh so sad
child predators have to ruin everything
yeah but like TLC has a weird um like
morality it's like that's where you draw
the line not like Sister Wives has been
on for 30 years there everyone says that
I have to watch this door it's the
greatest also like they have the Duggars
who are like very controversial but say
you're gonna kick off the [ __ ] uh
what is their last name yeah I guess
like well child I know but it's just
funny like that's where they draw the
line yeah you've got to watch sister
wives now they have so many like
spin-offs seeking sister wives where
like you're looking for the fourth
I love Sister Wives it's the most [ __ ]
up crazy-ass [ __ ] and the main the one
husband Kody is just so I've been deep
in there have you ever watched 90-day
fiance
no but you everyone loves oh I will we
got to do some like trade yeah I will
watch well you need to watch Potomac and
90 day fiancé okay not to run with love
that'll be for like for a rainy day
and then I'll watch sister wives and the
green scarf movie oh my god it's called
confessions of a shopaholic at least
have enough respect to say it right now
our final story is a great segue and she
just the travel and world news of the
day and it comes from a very prestigious
website called the points cocom and I
honestly need to just explain this whole
story because when we were together you
were talking about it just goes like
it's something but the Boeing stock
takes max takes a huge hit after the 737
max crash what is the 737 and what
happened and now just explain the whole
thing so for like 30 years is 737 it
like I'm sure everyone has flown on one
it's what Southwest it's all Southwest
three seats on each side three and three
it's like your medium-sized plane it's
like what a a flights to Miami
it's like what most like two three-hour
flights are on that's why we've all
flown on 737s the new generation is
called the max which had it has like new
features it's like you know slimmer
seats aka the airline's just jam more
people on it it's not really a
remarkable it's like the average it's
like the average aircraft that gets you
places you're never gonna remember it
but so Bowie it's their best-selling
plane and Boeing is what a company that
makes plane Boeing makes plane they do a
ton of stuff they do a lot of they make
fighter jets and all this stuff for
military but Boeing mostly isn't you
know they're known for their airplanes
747 the queen of the skies 747 is like
what you find internationally yeah
that's what we're flying Israel Israel
I'm so excited so anyway so Boeing so
this was like this is a new future
they've sold thousands of these planes
and about six months ago one of them
went down and brand-new planes don't
just crash mechanically how long were
they out in in the market before they
started crashing they came out I think
about a year or so ago maybe you're
knows it's very new it's very very new
and then six months ago Lyon air and
what's lying in Asia yeah it was
Indonesia it's so the plane took off and
went like crazy and then just crashed
everyone died so everyone was like shook
by this but Boeing said no no it's fine
like we'll work on it but like problem
so you know two weeks ago in Ethiopia
the same thing happened they took off in
Cooper buh-buh-buh-buh-buh and six
minutes in crash everyone's dead oh my
god so that's when like you know they're
very you know and it's hard you know
being at your computer trying to figure
out what's going on with the plane like
we don't leave it to the experts
well though it's coming out so basically
they knew there was an issue the plane
the sensors are wrong and and with these
new planes there's so much technology
where pilots can't take control they've
actually made these new sensors so in
case a terrorist gets on right they can
oh the terrorists are ruining everything
from the issue is like and in general
like most you know most plane crashes
are usually like pilot error oh really
so like I guess you know you got to give
it to like the airline manufacturers
they want to make it safer for
passengers but like when you go too much
and the thing is what we're finding out
and this is the real crazy stuff within
the last day or two that there's there
may be a criminal investigation into
boeing so they put this
new system but didn't train anyone it
was a one-hour iPad course for all the
global pilots in all different languages
but and so pilots had actually
complained about it and there's now news
that the government shut down because
the FAA was closed all these complaints
didn't get to the whole but then the
bigger drama is that our FAA is actually
run by Boeing that boeing has been greed
boeing has so much power they're the
number one exporter of u.s. goods
because they sell so many planes and
military equipment that they have
basically taken over the FAA the FAA
which used to be the FBI used to be the
gold standard of all the flight agencies
u.s. aviation so the FAA was the last to
ban the match so when these two planes
went down I immediately was like no TPG
employees flying on this right and then
you know it start cheyna was the first
and China was like hell no let's
granny's point let's be saved and the
the FAA was the last so our government
Boeing and it's you know bought it was
it you know you can you can extrapolate
from that which you want but it's shady
that Americans were flying on this plane
before you know and it's a dangerous I
mean pilots agree everyone is it's it's
it's a really sad story families have
any of the victims 2000% that's why
Boeing wanted to say oh no it's fine
keep going keep going
how crazy is that so putting profits
over but I've been on a 737 max in the
past year what LaGuardia Miami they yeah
and then we covered the Boeing that
American Airlines version is horrible
they actually Jam so many seats in the
airline of flight attendants Union is
complaining you've been in a 737 max on
American if you go into the bathroom and
it's so tiny you actually like I turn
you can't turn it's so jam-packed cuz
they put in so many seats oh my god
that's crazy yeah so another stock has
gone down stocks gone down so did
America ground up yes so finally like
last a week after everyone else grounded
them you know drama drama so too it's a
real kind of stain on American like
total aviation they and they're like oh
a computer fix is coming next month but
they were still flying the planes oh my
god that's so scary
so I think there's to pay more attention
yeah cuz maybe I was on one you're
probably very well could have so when
you book a flight do you check
what type of photo I've said this from
the very beginning like checking what
plane you fly is you know domestically
if you're on an hour or two flight like
if you're in coach like it's all the
same it's all roughly but in general
Airbus actually has wider seats you know
Airbus suite is Airbus a competitor
yelling so here's the story so Boeing is
US and Airbus is European so Airbus is
loving all the drama of course and now
people all these you know no one knows
how long these could be grounded for and
Boeing is making like six a day so now
they're starting to pile up its toes up
that's just stupid
but when you make an airplane it's like
two years of like surprise that come
into the final assembly so it's not the
end of the world I think they'll
probably come out with fixes but it's a
it's a big deal so but most airlines
have you know there's not that many of
them out there it's still a tiny
fraction of the total plane so like it's
not it's not like a majority of the
fleet's normal 737s are fine to fly so
if you see a that you're on a 737 you'll
be fine but what's the ideal plane like
if you're looking for a flight like a
3/4 okay so here's the thing oh so well
in general if you're going
internationally you should look to fly
787's a350s a380s these new types of
planes have better air filtration
they're actually the the mood lighting
it all helps with jet lag and their
choirs I've been seeing lewd lighting as
a trend yeah and it actually helps with
your jet lag so internationally like you
know if you want cheap flights to Europe
Norwegian air has almost all 787 just
flew you wanna hear a crazy story Ben
just flew Norwegian air to Florence and
he was in first class and there was
nobody sitting next to him so he was
like so excited but all the stuff in the
chair 45 minutes into the flight he
falls asleep and he wakes up and there's
someone assume did they self up great
upgrade themselves I don't know they
just like Cayman sad because he had
moved all Ben's stuff like into the
middle console so Ben got woken up by
like his hat rubbing on his arm and
there was some guys Nixon interesting
well the thing is once the planes in the
air it's the captain's flight and the
flight attendant so actually my friend
Jason and Caleb they they got upgraded
after the flight took off recently
because American Airlines had screwed up
the reservation but the flight
attendants not right so the flight
attendants can move you up to business
class they can it's it's always be nice
but be nice that's why we say if you're
super nice to people you go such a long
way it goes such a long wait flight
attendants if you're
nice and get to know flight attendants
even in business or first class like
I've had flight attendants give me
bottles of wine when I'm leaving my
friends did too like if it flight
attendants like you it's not a power
you've got so much power it's like
they're like fiefdom in the sky yeah
it's a once you would take off it's
there what's their world interesting and
also like with gate agents gate agents
get screamed at all day I mean I see it
like there's literally a tornado at
LaGuardia and lightning and people like
like don't be that person gate agents
have no control but if someone being
like relax like be nice I know but I oh
my god I wanted to say what do you what
would you would you have said I know
you're not confrontational and I
actually Channel so yes I got my flight
from Miami to New York I sit down and I
love Tom Ford fragrance but the guy the
guy next to me babe oh that's it was
like I was gagging I had that all the
vents on that so then I'm like freezing
cold and then he puts his feet I'm
almost his lips he put his feet up he
was literally heels to G's shoes on no
he had his socks on but they were like
yeah he was sitting like this I was like
and he smelled so bad I almost wanted to
you at the end of the flight just be
like I love your fragrance but like it
was really like really strong but then
I'm like I can't because no you can't
and honestly at the end of the flight
it's like that's pointless cuz you never
gonna see this guy again but I would say
if he was a toaster like yeah totally
but he would have said hi to me if he
wasn't ago but like there are certain
scenarios on a plane where like you
really don't know what to do like I had
a problem and I texted you like I was on
my way to Vegas to meet you when I was a
lay flatbed so the guy next to me fell
asleep and he was snoring so loud over
my headphones I was watching Entourage I
heard over my headphones so loud he
obviously like has a problem yeah he's
doing a situation like that you can ask
I mean usually I would just recommend
like go to the galley and just say ask
the flight attendant what they would do
cuz they can like I mean it's a dicey
situation and if he has a medical
problem right but I would always get the
flight attendant involved okay like go
to the bathroom that's a flight
attendant to like wake them up or ask
them maybe to like sleep up right yeah
or like on your side yeah only when you
sleep on your back when you sit on a
plane you sleep on your back I always
sleep on my side me too I actually said
by my belly sometimes cuz I'm so short I
could literally fit into any little pod
I love
I'm so excited I'm going to Phoenix you
know I have a problem tell me explain
this to me this is always what I like to
yell at you about like as if you can do
anything about it but I'm one of Phoenix
and I just went to Salt Lake
both 5-hour flights know all so I go to
LA and it's also a five-hour flight and
when I go to LA no matter what flight
I'm on it's always a lay-by bed there's
no layfayette to know and even like
sometimes San Diego to Phoenix weekend
tickets available all girl no job com
Brian's been to what 400 shows they're
so good keep getting better like yeah
you're singing oh then did say my show
up Foxwoods this weekend was the best he
ever heard me sing Wow and I'm working
out a nice project when I go to LA I was
so I'm so excited I'm sorry continue
so life let's yeah you know it just
depends but like certain fly like I flew
new to see you in Houston all the
flights are like terrible 737 but one a
day is a 767 so that's why I couldn't
see your version that's in your life
that's why it's important to look at
planes so it's like an advanced tactic
but like once you start flying a lot and
you want and you get upgraded or
whatever it like flying and especially
flying on a bigger plane so US airlines
will put international planes on random
routes like New York Miami is a 767
there's more business class seats so
your chance of getting upgrade is higher
so even when you're flying to LA there's
sometimes 767s on Delta versus 757 the
767 is twice as many business class
seats if you're booking coaches like a
platinum medallion your chances of
getting upgraded so that's why I like
understanding plane types and choosing
your routes if you have flexibility
right interesting and you have like
Rewards accounts with every single thing
on the planet
right yes I will fly like whatever
airline is like the most comfortable oh
really yeah
you're not biased no I mean I usually
will fly American because they're miles
I have top status and I can get more
value from miles but okay we're gonna
test your questions credit card we get
so many specific questions when people
meet you on the street are they like hey
Brian you know I'm in this I got this
amount of debt and I want this credit
nobody
so I even say that it's the funny thing
whenever people seem on the street they
will say I took this amazing trip like
that people always want to tell me about
their met and that's what makes it
that's what keeps me doing totally I
said well I just like literally when I
met you I had a debit card that's it and
I had no points then I got the Chase
Sapphire reserved not the better ones so
you talk to them about my problem I bet
your podcast
so funny you say it so - just today so
the Sapphire Reserve you earn more
points per dollar spent but it's a
50,000 points signup bonus and it's 450
year it's like a lot for the average
person so the preferred which I think
Jackie had accidentally got by absent
because it's confusing which is
preferred a which is respected thing is
to prefer to a great starter card and
actually starting today you earn 60,000
points with Shia you've earned 60
instead he used to be 50 yes Reserve is
50 so now on the Sapphire Preferred
starting today you get 60,000 points I
get grandfathered in for the extra
10,000 points no although actually if
you applied for a set by preferred
within the last couple months you can
always ask and say hey look there six do
you know always ask and would chase you
can send a direct message to your
account say hey it's now 60,000 can I
get that they may say no they may say
yes but it never part by two years in
the process you're not getting 10,000
points although it never hurts to ask a
lot of times if you're a good customer
at them when you're like hey it's 60
like the thing is it never hurts to ask
yeah I mean what group NBA thirstier
than the toaster nobody so ask for
points so anyway so today the Sapphire
it's so it's a ninety five dollar annual
fee but you get sixty thousand points
when you spend four thousand within
three months so just put everything on
it and you earn double points on all
travel and dining but dining so travel
includes uber airlines hotels oh yes I
knew and even Subway's gas or no not yes
tolls parking I also didn't know you can
connect your lyft account to your Delta
account it's a double dip yeah that's a
little tricks like that you also taught
me about the Delta shopping portal yes
when you're shopping online like always
shop like if you're gonna go to like you
know Nordstrom calm never go directly to
Nordstrom you can shop through airline
shopping portals so you basically go to
Delta SkyMiles shopping or advantage a
shopping you put your frequent flyer
number in and then it'll say like five
points per dollar at Nordstrom you click
the link it puts a cookie on your
computer and then you earn you know one
two up to ten and they have like flash
shelves ice it's like just today 30
miles per dollar so and that way you
earn miles from using your credit card
for shopping at Nordstrom and then you
also earn airline miles for shopping
through their portal double-dipping it
makes you feel better about
like it's rationalize all of your online
shopping you should be earning frequent
flyer miles so never never never never
never never go directly to a retailer's
website good call um we actually got a
lot of questions about the target card
do you know anything about it
the cache shows always make it sound so
easy but I feel like there has to be a
catch from Melissa Culp yeah you know
the store cards you know that first
purchase you say 10% and if you're
spending $500 it's 50 bucks so here's
the deal like with the normal card like
you know let's the Sapphire Preferred we
value chase points at two cents apiece
so 60,000 points is worth $1200 so even
if you're spending a thousand dollars
and you're getting 10% back you're
getting $100 on a store credit card
right so in order for you to get $1,200
in value you'd be spending 12 if you're
spending 12 on target right then maybe
but then even after that the target
points you're earning basically 1% back
if you the store credit cards are
generally not worth it if you want to
cash back credit card the city double
cash it's no annual fee and you earn 2%
back so there's no math it's it's all
about math you want to be maximizing
every dollar you spend so once you get a
credit card in the big sign up bonus you
also want to be maximizing like the
categories in which you spent if you're
spending a lot on seamless and Subway's
and uber get a card if they mint Subway
sandwiches and I was like well that too
that's double so then it's like so yeah
so then it's like the Sapphire Reserve
is triple points so if you're really
spending a lot the reserve does make
sense but the tip for everyone is if
you're new to the travel credit card
game you want to get the Sapphire
Preferred get the 60,000 and then down
the line you can always upgrade it to
the reserve and that happened today and
that happened today so if you creating
news and we actually have the link skate
right so it's at this point Scott Caan
slash toast if you go the all of TB G's
info is on there because it can be a
little confusing and this is probably
the most like basic question we got the
most from Amanda Kay's when do you cash
in on your rewards and when do you say
yeah so I know a lot of people are like
points hoarders where people like to see
their accounts grow and why should get
into points and like you see your
accounts against like hundred thousand
two hundred thousand you're like oh it
feels so good but here's the deal the
airlines and hotels like they generally
devalue points over time which means
like you know Delta ten years ago it was
like a hunger
thousand miles round-trip to go to
Europe I am going this week into Paris
it was 320,000 miles one way so the
airlines it's brilliant they shouldn't
they exactly so that there they keep
inflating so you don't want to wait
forever to use your points but you also
don't want to just squander them on
cheap flights right right
so and it also depends on your financial
situation if you're in debt I my
recommendation to anyone in debt get out
of debt no student loans a little mr.
great advice but like instead of racking
up and spending like so if you're in
debt I would say use your points for
everything and then pay down those bills
I gave number one focus instead of like
saving to go to Thailand in four years
get your bills get yourself out of debt
because if you're paying interest I mean
it's 20% APR it doesn't matter how many
points you earn you will be paying for
them many times over so really get
yourself to a place where you're out of
credit-card debt and then spend smartly
and you know get credit cards a one or
two a year with the 60,000 point bonus
that's you know 60,000 points is a
round-trip ticket to Europe totally and
you know in peak summer that's $2,000 so
yeah so basically get out of debt but
then put everything on credit cards and
pay them off every month this is from
Clare Conaty what in your opinion in
your professional opinion is the best
airline lounge like if you're taking an
international trip what is your
preferred lounge of choice so my
favorite of the u.s. Airlines American
Airlines has flagship so if you're
flying first-class or they can invite
certain people in so basically it's full
dining they have crew campaign it's
really really nice I would say and the
United Polaris lounges for business
class are the best but you have to be
flying business class internationally
see that's confusing cuz it's like so I
always I only fly Delta and that's like
what all my experiences and I always go
to the Delta Sky Lounge cuz I'm platinum
medallion when I have the plan and
business card that you told me to get
but so I always walk in and like when I
have a first-class seat I always think
that just gets me into the lounge
they're like no we need to see your
credit card why doesn't the first-class
seat just because there's so many people
flying first-class the lounge's would be
zoos I mean there are already zoo yeah
and you have to be so in general to get
into an airline lounge you have to be
flying internationally in business or
first or have top two your elite status
and fly coach or have an airline credit
card the thing is airline lounge access
is usually $600 and up the airline
credit cards that offer lounge access
like 450
a year rush you get all these other
perks so like never pay for lounge axis
you can get credit cards that will get
you in and you know the lounges are like
decent but you know the US airlines
charge for like nice tequila and nice
wine the best all-around is with the MX
platinum you can get into the Centurion
lounges the Centurion lounges you can
bring two guests and it's all you can
you know eat and drink like good food
and no upcharges for anything
yeah it's having an Amex Platinum or
business platinum if you have a business
I what okay so I haven't had Miss Platt
I'm gonna have four years and I'd
literally never been to a Centurion
lounge cuz where the hell is it there at
LaGuardia Miami where like and how do
you find it always a sign for the
delicacy lounge yeah cuz dealt so with
the MX platinum you get Delta lounge
access and you get Centurion shot
LaGuardia if you're flying Delta it's
right there that's right there it's the
Centurion lounge is by the American
Airlines side oh but I ever fly American
right so basically American Airlines
used to have lounge access with platinum
then one day they're like no we're gonna
only give it to City so that it Amex is
basically saying yeah yeah we're gonna
build these amazing lounges so they're
there in Houston there in Seattle Las
Vegas right even if you're find Delta at
Las Vegas you should go okay
cuz I've literally never been see at all
they're opening one in LA but I'm always
looking for it and there's never like a
sign for it or anything no cuz you're
that's why Delta I love Delta yeah but
the Delta lounge is like yeah you know
what they get the job done and then
they've grown a canned cheese oh yeah
there's snacks could use like a little
bit of an upgrade brush um we got a lot
of questions about people who commute to
work like they drive and they want to
rack up points for gas yes so the best
all-around so the city so there's but
think of it like this so there's three
main types of like bank credit cards
there's Amex so the Amex Platinum which
gets you in the lounges but it's not the
best for earning points you earn one
point the five on airfare but those
points transfer to different airlines
and in general learning the the way you
get ahead in points is learning how to
transfer your points from Amex
Chase and City - what - Airlines and
Capital One now actually so there's four
so there's four key Bank programs couple
one just added transfer points so you
know when you redeem them - like if you
go in Amex travel or chase travel
they're gonna give you like one cent per
point
flight so a $500 flights 50,000 points
at the same time if you transfer your
points so you shouldn't book it in the
chase Porto are you transfer but this is
but this is this is where like so we are
flying to Israel we actually transferred
Amex to ela uh-huh
and then we booked first-class for a
fraction of what it would it would have
cost like a million points each if we
would have purchased because I was
looking last night with then to book my
flight to Israel yes and I was doing it
on the AMEX portal yes so it's just
gonna price it based on like it's
because they're like $8,000 tickets yeah
so expensive like my ticket and I you
know at the cheapest level with United
which in United has our new planes on
the Israel route it's amazing oh I'm
doing yes yes so it's so we I used 180
thousand chase points and five dollars
so that got like versus let's see the
first class so so 180 thousand is gonna
get you have to help me it's gonna get
you like a $2,200 flight that ticket was
nine thousand dollars but I mean I used
one hundred and eighty thousand by
transferring divided and booking by
transit key is accruing points in these
portals but not using the portals for
anything other than transfer RAC correct
you have just solved yeah so if you buy
amazon merchandise you're getting less
than one cent if you buy a flight you're
getting one cent if you transfer them
book business class you can go up to
like eight cents a point so but in that
it gets a little tricky you got to
figure out the transfer partners and
that's why this summer we're coming out
the TPG app which by the way you just
have to come out with it already
it's gonna change lives I know cuz every
dinner party I go to and people are like
people actually do ask so I want to go
to Italy on these nights and that's how
about started almost like as a concierge
before I was a blog people would pay me
50 bucks and I would just like use my
knowledge to help book amazing trips so
crazy so now we're actually gonna get
back to that by we're gonna track your
points we're actually gonna even finding
the right credit card can be like why
Jesus I don't know how much do I spend
on gas right so we're gonna actually
link up to your bank accounts and most
scan what you spend your money on oh my
god like mint and will actually say with
points and then you can say I want to go
to Croatia this summer and we'll
actually then pull it all in and we'll
say use these credit cards and then this
airline actually has availability that
is so into our logic for you until then
but if you Google like the points guy
how to maximize my chase points Amex
points we have like tons of blog posts
about how to do it
so what I love about points
it's a currency that the more you mind
your knowledge the more valuable your
points become and that's why when people
get into the transfers and you do it the
first comment is and it's like a little
bit like stressful you're like am i
doing it right and then you redeem that
trip to Israel for five alliterative
five dollars and sixty so you recommend
transferring credit card points to
Airlines do you recommend transferring
airline points like between airline
partners you can't transfer between
airline partners like you can't transfer
your Delta points to Air France but you
can redeem Delta on Air France but a lot
of times you have to call the airline
and be like I want to fly again and I
want to use these miles generally when
the airline website shows you an option
there's there's cheaper options out
there but you kind of have to go hunt
for them so the key for people who are
looking to save money on flights is to
open credit cards with good that are
good for your situation to accrue those
points and then transfer those points
directly so what you want you want a
good sign up bonus you want good
category bonuses you you want to be
earning more than one point per dollar
if you're earning one point per dollar
on most of your spend you're doing it
wrong got it so like at the toast
landing page the points got our comm
slash toast we've got like the cards
we've identified four toasters but then
I'm also gonna be popping into the so
for those who are in our morning
toasters Facebook group which hopefully
everyone is we have a million subgroups
and we just started one called the
successful save scenes which she didn't
understand the reference but it's a
confessions of a shopaholic reference
where she works at successful savings to
them right the girl a bit and I have you
ever done like a lot I will come in in a
green scarf and do a live oh my god yes
okay but the successful save scenes
group it's just for people who like want
to learn more about credit cards about
points share tips and tricks so we're
gonna be sharing a bunch of tips in
there too so go apply successful save
the Steen's I'll put in the group just
so people can learn I feel like I've had
you on the show 1000 times and I'm
learning today more than ever I feel
sometimes like I finally I mean you were
a little thick oh yeah yes no I'm
understand it's getting a little warm in
here I'm gonna do a little outfit change
Oh what yeah I by now if they change are
you literally walked in with a garment
bag yeah what are you gonna put on I'm
scared so basically the goal is once you
once you get don't look once you get
this a fire preferred then like it you
like will graduate all right everyone
just hang tight for those in the podcast
brian is taking his shirt off and he's
brought a garment bag I thought you were
going somewhere else after this like
some are more important where you needed
a blazer
because you were also on Ryan and Kelly
I want to talk to you about that because
he saw Colton he was there the same days
Colton and Cassie and he was in the
greenroom with them oh my god that is so
funny
okay you guys put your mic back on Bryan
for this jacket to the TPG Awards when
this card the safe a Chase Sapphire
reserved one credit card of the year yes
and now you're wearing it again damn it
really I know right the chase executive
they had a big chase conference and they
actually asked to borrow its [ __ ] did
you have it made yeah so Jon my friend
our friend he works in the theater
Broadway and he was a costume designer
and theater so this was like an old tux
blazer but so basically Chase Sapphire
reserve one credit card of the year yeah
what does it say as the name on that
glows credit card that is so epic and
that credit card today went up to 60,000
this note so the preferred which is the
junior card they need to change the
names of these two cards they're too
similar preferred reserved but the gold
today get the Sapphire Preferred to
60,000 points it's the $95 version it's
like the ease in card but then down the
line when you're ready to get like a big
Daddy card that's what you are Big Daddy
so you get in with the preferred and
then you migrate down the line because
you get more points with preferred it's
not I'm like crunching yeah I know it's
very country it's a stand really
straight that's good for you but I like
attention so you look great thank you
okay we got so many more questions you
just have to have a launch date for the
app yet launch date will be July but
we're actually gonna be doing testing
with the app we actually just came out
with an initial test so we're gonna be
testing and actually doing events all
around the US over the next four months
but the app should launch in July okay
I'm very excited maybe we'll do like a
TPG sponsored birthday party cuz my
birthday shall I attend and we'll push
the app yeah what's the best card for a
college student trying to build credit
okay so college students and I was just
at Davidson College last week you're so
like do you get tired just like you what
do you get home last week was exhausting
what do you consider so my home is Miami
but I'm in New York all the time and on
airplanes and I'm gonna I'm going to the
UK next week we're launching in London
in Brazil so I'm like really you're a
man of the world man of the world JFK is
your airport I mean is your home so the
best part for college students so
there's several it depends
what your credit score is so everyone
should get your free credit score annual
credit report.com most people some
people can get like a decent credit card
at first i would say like a freedom so
the thing with Chase is you start with
the freedom what's your credit score 780
it goes up and down because cuz you have
20 credit cards I have 25 one it's not
because of credit cards but because we
put like a million dollars a month and
businesses rights on my cards right and
that's the biggest factor is like how
much yeah it's like they give you credit
but they yell at you for using it it's
[ __ ] that's not I like have the
worst credit I don't know why they I
don't know what's like in the sixes
what's ya know it's a big problem well I
think the big thing is you're probably
like I mean are you paying your bills
off ah [ __ ] I pay my bill multiple
[ __ ] times a month so I could get
more money okay
I'm always calling like [ __ ] can you
raise my credit limit and they're like
no maybe there's a reason why that
you're not yeah I know why I called you
ready gonna die you're gonna die don't
know if I told you this I have a
negative recent public record I don't
know everyone's always talking [ __ ]
about me online major credit report
come try a what's a good what's a good
credit report okay is there someone you
could talk to at Credit Karma calm
actually your Chase Sapphire will give
you a free FICO score so get your
[ __ ] psycho and get the report and
it'll show you the Rifai cosa real score
so Experian there's all these like
credit Karma's gonna give you like a
finest check right now and your your
your Chase Sapphire reserve if that gets
free FICO right K like so but nah keep
that question about college student so
if you can get a freedom no annual fee I
like the freedom unlimited it's one and
a half points on everything the thing is
once you build a relationship there then
you can graduate to a Sapphire Preferred
or Reserve and then those points instead
of being cashback they become
transferable which we talked about
transferring points is like the ninja
mode of points if you can't get a
Freedom Card you Discover's also all
discover cards have no annual fees the
commercials are annoying as [ __ ] yeah
but and they're like just cash backed or
decent and if you can't get any credit
card you can get and a lot of people who
move to the u.s. and need to establish
credit you can get a secured credit card
where you have to put five hundred
dollars on the card and you like pay it
off every month but having a secured
credit card for like six months will
usually get your credit score
as long as you pay it in full every
month it'll shoot your score up to the
point you really only need like a 680 or
so to get a decent credit card of course
getting you know out of 850 points you
want to be above 700 once you get above
750 that's excellent and it doesn't
really make a difference but I mean the
goal is to get above 700 but even at six
sixty seventy eighty you might be able
to get as long as you have nothing
negative on your report the number one
the note FICO puts on their website you
go to FICO and look at the pie chart the
number one aspect of your FICO credit
score is payment history so never ever
ever miss a payment even if you can
automatic payments yeah so set up
automatic payments at a very minimum
just the minimum payment will be fine of
course you want to pay it in full and
then the number two is how much
available credit you have so actually
having more credit cards and more
available credit and using less of it
increases your score okay I was out here
in discover calm like try it my FICO
credit score and like they wanted me
make a password it was too long
I just want to find out what my credit
score is because I got everyone watching
should you should know your credit score
those commercials like are so annoying
but also informative yes and we'll put
in the savvy saving steam successful
savings safe seems like how to get your
credit score well do a post there's a
lot of credit cards that'll give you
your FICO score for free if not we'll
put links on that because credit
education I love points and especially
cuz so many toasters are young I want
everyone to be educated understand what
goes into credit because your credit
score is an asset if you mess up your
credit score it's gonna affect you for
many years to come and if it is messed
up there are clear ways to get it back
on track the first thing is if you have
something negative on your report always
call most creditors will actually give
you a pass the first time oh really
but don't poo do you call it credit
okano call the credit agency or you know
even a Verizon though I was stupid my
fraternity house moved and I like didn't
do any address forwarding that's forward
three years later I was in collections
from Verizon and they gave it to a
collection age
my head in the sand I knew the bill was
there but I was like whatever they're
gonna forget about it yeah they don't
forget about it and it will haunt you so
you know it's not a fun thing to face
that side of it but you there are clear
steps to getting to good credit so the
longer
put it off that it compounds how hot
much harder it is so if you miss a
payment call right away be nice and I
suppose automatic payments yeah I never
like think to pay my bills I just do it
my rent is on automatic payment ooh well
we're gonna put all of these helpful to
bits on the points go calm slash toast
in the successful save scenes group and
then also in the morning toast our
Facebook group so make sure you're just
checking those out to stay in tune with
what's necessary thank you to the points
guy for coming in a look because we
appreciate that so much here on the
chest you look so great keep up with the
points guy and all that the points guys
doing on Instagram at the points guy and
personally if you just want to see like
glamorous photos of me we're gonna see
Oklahoma on Thursday the at the bat
Brian Kelly right NK there's ly3 Brian
Kelly's do you know that well Florida
Georgia line those crazy fans will send
me some really and tits no tits but they
sent me some leg that's so funny
there's you and then there's also like a
football coach yep Notre Dame but you
are at Bri a and you have a job Brian
Kelly I got it I got it killing it and
we're gonna be launching a vlog soon of
my travels yeah Ellie but don't follow
it you up because we're doing in Tel
Aviv too right well I'm so excited
would you guys watch a vlog of Claudia
and I traipsing around Tel Aviv of
course I would it's called my Instagram
story thank you for being here thank you
guys for tuning in Jackie's back
tomorrow because she is officially off
of jury duty she just texted me she has
been let go so unfortunately she won't
be serving her civil services but she's
back here on the toast doing her civil
service here thank you guys have a great
day bye safe travels safe travels bum
boy
you